really not waste their 20s well your
value decreases as a woman the older you
get and your opportunity to give a man
children um it's less and less the older
you get yeah you can have
ivf but most guys don't want to spend
like what is it 30k
16k 16k yeah i work most of the time
yeah so i mean if a guy can pick you
know a 35 year old woman or a 25 year
old woman he's going to pick the 25 year
old woman you think so yeah why because
of the ability to be for fertile yeah
partially and like men
they surveyed men between the ages of
like 20 and 80 and all of them
prefer girls around the age of 22 23.
yeah this is what rola was saying sexual
the sexual marketplace so um i mean i
think there's other sexual market value
i don't want to mess that up yeah i mean
i think there's other things that come
into play but i think men when it comes
to building a family and you also have
the issue of you know the more
relationships that a girl has been and
the more traumatized she's going to be
the more she the more access she has to
complain about yeah and that just
happens the older you get well let me
let me actually give you a different
side of the coin because i remember you
were very um
open about this you said you are so much
better of a woman as a female as a
girlfriend at 30 31 as you were at 24.
yeah explain why i feel in your 20s you
just you're starting to learn who you
are and you see what you like when you
dislike and
i think that in your 20s
you shouldn't be dating somebody
like if you're 21 22 you should not be
in a relationship for like five years
i think you should if it happens great
good for you but i think that you should
explore who you are as a person and by
that you can also date multiple guys so
you can see what you like what you're
dislike so you think that a woman who's
21 22 she gets out of college she should
go through her whole face you never said
that i said it you did
no i never said you should go through a
whole face you said date multiple guys
so i did not say it has to be oh but we
know what i mean i think you should
live your life
and see who you are so then later on
when you're ready and when you're
emotionally mature because when you're
21 2 you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on at least i didn't i mean i
moved here when i was 22. so in this
past eight nine years i changed a lot
because i learned who i am
what if i got married to a guy that i
was dating when i was 21 22 because my
goal in life was to get married i would
i didn't know who i am okay so how can
you get married
and be with somebody
but you're not even
sure who you are yeah so how do you guys
grapple with that because you're
basically saying the exact opposite
thing that she's saying so would you
guys engage and have this i don't
understand what that means you don't
know who you are you're trying to figure
out what you want in life like i just
i've always known who i am well not
everybody is the same
i just don't get what girls mean when
they say that
what what is it like they want to just i
mean i get it they kind of want to
figure it out
so i think there's some truth to some of
the things that coco says because
one of the reasons that pearl probably
knew who she was when she knew it is
because you had really great parents
well-rounded two-parent household but i
i actually don't agree entirely with you
know the red pill about oh go ahead and
get out there and get a husband as young
as you can i think you have the most
leverage in your youth i can agree to
that i think you have a lot more options
at 20 to 24 but i can say that i don't
think most american women know
themselves until they're 24 and then i
mean even after that like there's a lot
of narcissistic clueless women running
around out here and they're going to be
a liability the problem is is that they
let the narcissism run its way into
their 30s and they're surprised like why
didn't my life work out it's because you
need a reality check and that's i think
that's why pearl and i have the content
that we do to just give women a heads up
like hey like your 20s you could really
be on a mission so you want to talk
about oh i want a career and i want a
husband okay fabulous amazing set it up
by 24. if you're hard charging and
you're an intelligent woman you can set
it up for at 24 and then you can pursue
dating full force can you define just
set it up by 24. have a foundation of
platform you can have a bachelor's
degree if you want you can have
internships you can have connections
networking whatever you need as a
foundation so that way
you've done most of the hard work and
you can still take on that relationship
and continue to do harder work in your
career if you need
a question for you guys
um
is an easy answer but also a complicated
answer are men and women equal no no
no
men and women did you ant did you say no
as well
i didn't vocalize but yeah they're not
equal
explain why men and women are not equal
go ahead alley you want to go first
we're just not the same we're not the
same and if we're not the same then how
could we be equal so we can talk about
you know women being equal but i'm not
even sure that that's a worthwhile
conversation because there's always
going to be somebody that has advantages
in different areas compared to
yourselves men are stronger and they're
bigger and they can run faster because i
don't know if you know this but strength
is it's sprinting is more about strength
like i can't sprint at all and then
there's things i'll beat your ass in a
race right now girl
right you know and uh so i can attest to
that because a lot of women think that
they're as strong as a man and that's
that's just not physically possible they
have so much more to solve what about in
the in the workforce are men and women
equal no no there should not be
professional women cry in the bathrooms
a lot i don't think men do that
my boss did
because you and ally both said no
immediately and then coco took a second
she thought about it but why why do you
say when men and women are not i didn't
think about it i just didn't say it okay
well i just men and women are different
we're not the same we're biologically
different like we're just not yeah well
our women are chemically different every
single day so even like i run a pretty
successful youtube channel i have a show
similar like similar to this setup in my
living room and i like bring people in
and a lot of my business decisions are
run through men and i think a lot of
times you're going to find like
successful women there's like a man
behind them helping them with the
decisions because like men are just more
logical than women because again we get
our emotions into it because we're
chemically different every single day
but the counter argument that i hear
okay as well you know men have been
running the world for years
and aren't all the wars started by men
that's not true
this is the counter argument that you
hear men start all the wars world war
one world war ii french revolution
america it's all men starting to written
genghis khan the mongols they they do it
all but they also built the world boom
so they they allowed
they allowed us to enter the workforce
they had to tame the world so we could
enter it
like if we were still in like the old
days we would need someone to protect us
so you guys are not male haters
whatsoever your male appreciation no i
mean shout out to the men out there i
have i've built in the world i mean i
have five brothers so when girls say
things like men or trash men are the
problem
i'm like okay you can speak for yourself
like the men you pick are the problems
because i i have five really great
brothers i have a really great father
and so if you have an issue with men
like that's a you problem and don't put
that on me by the way that is very
powerful go ahead coco i want to add
just because he's a good brother doesn't
mean he's a good boyfriend
well yeah but that's on the girl to pick
you pick who you date like if you're
halfway a decent looking girl you have a
million options who you can date so i'm
not gonna when these girls come crying
to me because they hate all the boys
they they chose to date like that's your
own fault i mean i agree with that
whenever like i have this thing called
wobble cocodo every tuesday and friday
and i put a little question box and
people ask me questions
and they are sending me you know
screenshots and their issues and they're
explaining what this guy did but i'm
like you're letting this happen so let's
say you have a guy who only invites you
over for netflix and chill and you still
show up and then you're expecting him to
like put you on a pedestal and fly you
to paris or something but like you're
letting it happen and those are the same
girls that'll cry on tick tock and be
like oh boo hoo poor me and i'm like i
don't feel bad for you
i don't you picked him this must be
controversial with the women like you're
friends with you grew up with this is
not like are they like you're a woman
hater you're like but i'm a woman okay
i've picked bad guys before too i'm not
perfect but in every situation i've been
in i was like you know what that was my
own damn fault
it usually is our fault yes
that is really hard to do whether in a
relationship or in the workforce look
yourself in the mirror and be like i
gotta own this l right here it's because
of my dad every time i try